welcome to this video playing women
international master Alan Helen oops
Ellen ha gustado Sato ok let's let's
play something outside had so many
Queens gambit recently let's go for the
London if black is committed to e 60
again this crappy stone wrong which
which I lost recently in a in a actually
very nice position yeah she's playing
with Bishop e7 up with Bishop b6 and
this runs into this G phone line which
is very tough to play for black I am
actually got into this position once as
black against a restaurant GM was lawn
chair back off from the from o.c from
Russia or Ukraine click on Russia on and
yeah I got into this is blackened and I
can remember that analysis afterwards
sir very it was a bit like you know
every Russian schoolboy knows you cannot
play the stone wall like that okay so
Bishop d6 how to how to play here could
take here play 95 someone idea okay
let's not spend ages here
fe 495 okay here i thought just this
would be good isn't it unfair she
retreats I take f5 okay but now okay hmm
this looks really ugly in my book 92
where to go yeah probably this is good
just go to d2 oops Wow Queen ashore what
the heck
whoo yeah this is a nice trick I didn't
see that at all yeah I need to take it
what can you do check it's actually not
not a huge problem because um check this
is still a pretty good position I think
so maybe h3 yeah okay it's a bit
debatable but I want to get things going
here sm so much better developed so it's
if I have a hard time to comprehend the
museum I can I can take it I can take g3
ok scrap here this was the idea I take
look everyone came it isn't this I've
got all the pieces in play ig5 coming
check still a pretty good pretty good
attack isn't it
ideas root g5 here yeah this all feels
like I'm missing many moves I don't know
sometimes you have this feeling that
okay what the opponent is doing it
shouldn't really work but you don't you
don't find the Y g7 how do you defend
that now Brooke b7 g6 I can take it it's
a it's a cute made this is also made
check rook h5 made I probably was was
not defensible anyway I now at least
black resigned yeah what a weird game I
mean I completely missed the special b3
of course so hard to tell what what this
position is I have half pieces in play
this is not playing here so maybe it is
good for white it's really difficult to
say check ya around here it gets it gets
very very tricky at the computers
showing a big big edge for what yeah
it's probably too much I really have a
strong attack and here it's losing again
one point was that g6 I can I can just
take check leading to check me to a
nice-nice meteor and what she did this
is similar check mate made in two moves
oh but let's just go quickly back to to
the opening should be six move yeah I'm
not quite sure i have i have other moves
i can also take f5 not sure what's the
best year the computer wants to go
Bishop g3 I didn't consider that okay
and this is probably not good then
because of exactly what you play it
honey check no a computer computer
actually wants to back to back up to d7
and gives black an advantage
hmm how to how to digest that really
okay let's c FR i mean this is this is
looking all very strange for black but
something like this is something let's
say here for for example yeah yeah like
us in the game no doubt it's all very
strange but maybe it's okay so i didn't
really play play the best way on Bishop
d6 never saw that war so this is good
according to the calm hmm interesting
yeah if you look at it and I you you
used to see the the point this now sets
up the idea to take one of five leading
to a very nice structure and like it's
not really able to take on g3 in any
case like like this I mean this is just
just nice opening up the file edit so
it's a healthy structure same with
Bishop d3 and this now is a very nice
white get to get the night 24 so black
is probably going to play some oops so
move like let's say here that you can
answer with a three of everything else
fails yeah this is a nice i need to play
here of course i didn't see that the
sole factor with Bishop e3 of it was
very cute okay thanks for watching